mental health is a critical issue not
only in the U.S but all over the world
since the pandemic started people
reporting episodes of depression or
mental illness has tripled and in some
cases quadrupled
we're going to meet a man now who has
dedicated his life to finding solutions
for that please meet Rob who is here uh
talking about his motivational speaking
and also
Maharaja I should say you address mental
health along the way too yes
hi nice to meet you it's good to be with
you today thank you for having me on the
show yeah um yeah what I do is I take
people's stories and how they overcome
their struggles rather than we have to
go see sets with a psychologist or
something I mean sometimes that happens
and you have to but rather than do that
or go into a dark place or depressed
place if you hear someone else's story
that's what I do so you tell your story
and your struggles from where you were
in life to where you are today how you
overcome those hurdles that's what I do
I love that because we are wired as
human beings to understand and learn
through storytelling yes and that's that
is a big focus of what you do you share
not only other people's stories but your
own you've had some travails along the
way I do I do that and I share that with
all my fans I call them my rosters and I
tell them about my struggles of certain
things like just like in my book I tell
the last story it's about me some little
parts of my life about being abused by
my stepfather and on different things
like that and it didn't hold me back in
today's society we find a lot of people
being held back by the struggles they're
they're having and I'm not saying that
it's a small struggle because everyone
can handle a situation to an extent and
some people get stuck they go into a
dark place let's say with a heartbreak
you're heartbroken and you go in your
bed cuddle up and you forget about life
yeah you know but this is what you
wanted to know you are not alone
Millions go through a similar situation
that's almost just right there like
yours and if they can do it you can do
it too so much power in that and you are
reaching so many people you said you
just got back from Paris yes as a matter
of fact let's talk about your book a
little bit uh you have your life
experiences with raw this is uh again
stories of different people who have
overcome or moved through very difficult
scenarios and if you hear some of the
stories that's why I said it's untold
stories Hidden Truths it's stories of
back from way back then like in the 80s
90s even the 70s where woman was abused
there's a story where a woman her
husband beat her stripped her naked and
make her walk the streets while people
watched yeah and she still sending the
story to tell me I forgive him raw wow
and she brought up her four kids and
whatever she did but she overcome that
mental place that she was in it's like
no turning back and this is how
beautiful the stories are powerful
stories in this book you've written
three others including two children's
books congratulations all of that thank
you your YouTube channel we want to tell
people where they can find you we want
to thank St media for sponsoring this
segment first of all but you can learn a
lot more and get more information about
Rob by visiting any of his social media
sites we'll have a connection to that on
our website and you can see right there
on your screen some of the info again
check us out as well to get connected to
all love what you're doing and it is so
needed right now we'll be right back
thank you so much